hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Joseph Butler in sermon number nine upon
forgiveness of injuries is going to talk
about how anger leads us astray and he's
got a really great metaphor or analogy
that he's using that of a distorting
lens that he's he's very committed to
he's going to exploit this to it maybe
you could say it's full possible extent
and so before we jump into that let's
remind ourselves of something that
Butler is committed to anger is a
passion that was implanted in our human
nature and we can use it properly it
does have some you know legitimate
purposes or functions or ends God gave
it to us so that we can try to protect
ourselves and those who matter to us and
also to promote General benevolence to
you know be good to other people but
anger does tend to mislead us and it
doesn't do so just affectively in terms
of how we feel right or even just in
terms of action but also there's a very
important point cognitively so you know
anger makes us
judge things and assume things and infer
things
wrongly and these are thoughts not just
feelings or desires because the two of
them are you know connected together so
early on in sermon nine he tells us and
he's got this you know great metaphor
that many people have used
um he says that this supposes every man
in private cases to pass sentence in his
own cause so you know this is a a
problem that's acknowledged by many if
there's some sort of dispute between
different people you don't want one of
the disputants to be made the judge
right uh or to be the one who's calling
all the shots and then notice what else
he says here who is the judge anger or
resentment the anger resentment inside
of you not you as a whole but the anger
resentment inside of you is the job
judge in these cases and he says well
the problem with this is that we're
subject to numberless partialities and
what is a partiality it's where we
privilege or prioritize our own
Viewpoint needs desires over those of
others that exist and should probably be
on an equal plane for ourselves with our
own and so he goes on and he says from
these numberless partialities which we
all have everyone would often think
himself injured when he was not so this
is one thing that we often get wrong did
somebody actually do wrong to us not
just did they harm us but that they do
what Butler is calling injury which you
could also translate is Injustice did
they did they wrong us or did they just
you know stumble against us and bump
right
so that's one thing that we get wrong
and then we also get right if we are
actually injured well how much how how
much did they do to us how bad is the
thing that they're doing and then I
think we could also include he doesn't
talk about here that here directly In
this passage but if we read between the
lines whether they did it to us rightly
I mean he's he's talking about a context
in which people get angry at other
people for having gotten angry with them
so if I do something inconsiderate and
careless and screw up somebody else's
day and they get angry at me and then I
get angry at them I'm evaluating their
own anger as if it's something against
me that I don't deserve right and maybe
I actually do deserve their anger so
whether they get angry at me rightly or
not I can be wrong about that and our
our our tendency to focus on ourselves
and see things through our own Matrix of
needs desires assumptions habits and all
that that's what what produces this
problem a little bit later he's going to
talk about self-love and this will where
this will be where he actually talks
about
um Media or things that get in the way
but also mediate our looking at other
things so he says that self-love is a
medium of a peculiar kind it makes us
look at things differently how so he
says in these cases cases of anger it
magnifies everything which is a Miss in
others so that guy over there who's you
know blowing his nose in a way that I
don't like he's doing something bad
right look at that disgusting slob over
there right and then when we do stuff we
tend to say oh it's everything is fine I
didn't intend anything bad you know what
I'm doing is innocent so we lessen
everything amiss in ourselves Butler is
saying we're all subject to this
distorting effect this distorting
cognitive effect how we weigh what's
going on how we interpret other human
beings actions and he also talks about a
number of ways this happens he says
without knowing particulars
um you know I I take upon me to assure
all persons who think they've received
indignities or injurious treatment that
they may depend on it as in a manner
certain the offense is not as great as
they themselves imagine we are in such a
particular situation with respect to
injuries done to ourselves that we can
scarce anymore see them as they really
are then our eye can see itself all
right I can't look at it off except
maybe in a mirror right or I don't know
camera lens or something like that
but you know he says if we could
actually Place ourselves as he calls it
at a do distance that is be really
unprejudiced we would frequently discern
that to be in reality in advertence and
mistaken our enemy which we now fancy we
see to be malice and scoring so this
shows us one of the not just cognitive
effects but one of the possible
cognitive remedies for the anger that we
feel and experience we could actually
try to look at situations in a less
Prejudice way can we be totally
unprejudiced probably not right but we
can certainly be more or less and that
way we can place ourselves at a due
distance and say well how would somebody
else an impartial Observer regard what's
being done here and if we do that maybe
we won't get as angry so that's some
very interesting stuff about self-love
right and then he tells us another thing
anger or hatred itself can be considered
as he says as another false medium of
viewing things he also talks about a
false light which anger sets things in
so we have two different and
distinguishable
sets of distortions going on we have the
self-love which makes us more liable to
take the things that other people are
doing
as reasons we should be angry with them
once we actually are angry or if we've
developed hatred in relation to that
person that is a second
distorting effect and what does that do
so anger tends to keep us stuck in the
situation of feeling angry and aiming at
retaliation how does it do so so
he tells us that we represent
characters and actions as much worse
than they actually are he says ill will
not only never speaks but never thinks
well of the person towards whom it is
exercised so the whole character and
behavior is considered with an eye to
that particular part which has offended
us the whole man appears monstrous
without anything right or human in him
whereas the resentment should surely at
least be confined to that particular
part of the behavior which gave offense
since the other parts of a person's life
and character stand just the same as
they did before and he's saying well
you know what does happen we globalize
we you could say
characterize and we say I know who that
person is they are all bad right and so
if we see them that way then we can you
know retaliate not just against the one
thing that they did but against who they
are in general you always do this sort
of thing is that sort of refrain right
and what is Butler trying to aim at here
this is where the metaphor of the lens I
think is is very very helpful he tells
us that
um we want to make allowances for these
sorts of things and so he says it it
belongs just as much to bad people who
will indulge the vice I'm arguing
against as to good people who Endeavor
to subdue it in themselves to try to
look at things let's call it more object
actively more impartially
when they get angry they need to remind
themselves that anger has this
distorting effect and so following out
with this metaphor he says all these
questions concerning anger and self-love
are no more than Desiring that a person
who is looking through a glass which
either magnified or lessened to take
notice that the objects are not in
themselves what they appear through that
Medium so if you know that you're
looking through a distorting medium you
can adjust for that if you don't know
that well then you assume that the
reality is true so being aware of the
distorting effects that self-love has
and then the distorting effects that
anger or hatred once you're actually
angry or hating somebody also
contributes to the mix can be incredibly
helpful
for not going too far with your anger
not retaliating in the wrong way not
remaining angrier than you ought to be
and not globalizing about people or
perhaps even going beyond that to entire
groups of people and being angry or
hateful towards them for the one offense
that this person did here which might
not even be an injury in the first place
so these are some really helpful
Reflections and arguments that are being
provided here by Joseph Butler about how
anger and self-love distort our views on
things